how'd it get started in the food
franchise business if you're running a
company a great way to be able to expand
is through franchising and it's great
because you're not using your capital to
expense you can quickly grow a company
up because other people are investing
into their individual stores to help you
launch this bigger enterprise I got a
great question from one of my readers
George on Facebook who wrote in to say I
want to start my own food franchise
business can you maybe make a video on
youtube so George this one is for you
now to have success in the food
franchise business or in any franchise
business the key thing here this is
where most people get it wrong the most
important thing that you need to start
with is one successful location you have
to have one location that is making good
money that people will want to replicate
too many entrepreneurs think I'm going
to franchise this concept out is going
to be great and they start pitching this
thing they start trying to get on
franchisees where they haven't even
built one successful location themselves
you have to show that it works because
what are people buying at the core
people are buying a franchise system
that works you're telling them here are
the steps that you need to go through to
achieve success as a franchisee you're
taking people who want to be an
entrepreneur who don't have an idea
themselves or who or a little too afraid
to launch up their own business so they
want to be their own boss and follow a
set of rules the rules have to work you
have to show that they work right and
that comes from you having a really
successful location so the best
franchises in the world are the ones
who've started with one great location
so you've got to make it work before you
even start thinking franchising before
we think expansion create one restaurant
and make it work that's hard enough
that's a huge battle because most
restaurants fail so make one work for
you and then from there you can think
about expansion and franchising is one
of your options the other thing to think
about franchising and this is going to
be down the road but when you start
becoming a franchisee or if you are
going to be bringing on franchisees
you have to understand that your role
now changes because your main role in
the business is going to be managing the
franchisees and all of their questions
and recruiting and training you're not
running your your restaurant anymore
you're not running a restaurant business
you're running a franchise business and
a lot of entrepreneur friends of mine
who have gone down that road of
franchising regret it because they feel
disconnected from their business they
get into a different business now where
you are managing these franchisees so
you have to figure out is this the
business for you or not it's something
to think about down the line but your
number one step here is not even
thinking about franchising yet make your
restaurant work and this goes for
anybody who's trying to raise capital
you try to grow your company out you
want investors to come on if it's an
equity investor franchise investor or
whatever it is show that what you have
works
don't come them with an idea they'll
come to me with a business plan just on
paper with nothing actually physical
show me that what you have works show me
that people are interested in this
concept show me that the market is
blowing up and you need money to expand
that's where most people fall down and
that's why most people don't get the
investment they need and they don't get
the franchisees that they need and you
want good franchisees a bad franchisee
is going to sink your company you're
going to invest so much time in training
and working with them and it's not it's
not working out because you brought the
wrong person in from the start you are
good franchisees you have to have a good
system people are going to invest in and
that comes from having a great location
they can start with so that's your
number one step make that work make your
one restaurant highly successful highly
profitable and then you're ready to
expand the look at franchising or
different options to grow your business
believe those are you watching you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below
thank you George North to the question
and if you guys have a question for your
business or comment leave it below I
love seem to come in they really make my
day every time I see them so thank you
so much keep the comments coming and
I'll see you soon
you